everyone this is Peter Brown standing in
for freelance reviewer Daniel Starkey
for their early access review of for
tonight almost every moment of fortnight
is a chaotic mess for better and for
worse it's an action-packed shooter that
knows how to encourage cooperation
between team members and as a result
you'll often build out hasty force with
friends to defend yourselves from hordes
of cartoonish beasts that part is
usually a thrill and highlights all the
best pieces of what should be a solid
formula building basis with friends to
defend against monsters
however the reality of that is selling
far more often than it should be by a
mesmerizing deluge of content for
starters for tonight isn't even an easy
game to describe it staples together
pieces of disparate genres into
something entirely new combines the
construction elements and resource
gathering of Minecraft the team-based
shooting of left4dead
and Gears of War the quest design of a
modern MMO and the progression of any
given free-to-play hit it's surprising
that such divergent elements work
together at all
but fortnight definitely knows what its
best at and tries to thrust you into
ideal scenarios early on fortnight is
quite content to keep its writing in
tone rooted firmly in the realm of the
comedic instead of any serious moves to
address the story behind an apparent
zombie invasion you get a solid stream
of jokes instead
[Music]
fortnight's undead look about as
threatening as a Furby a bit creepy in
the right lightfoot otherwise harmless
if you're trying to bust down a wall
it'll pop and flex with each strike as
if ripped from a Looney Toons skip every
character you find will be some
over-the-top caricature of a classic
disaster slash horror movie trope in
your main companion for example is a
finicky bot that only partially knows
how to run your shelter that task is
ultimately up to you as you organize
expeditions to gather other wacky folks
to join your band all while seeking out
whimsical tech such as sky lasers to
help cleanse the world of ghouls early
missions teach you the basics of defense
and shooting after that you're tossed in
with three or four other players and
told to stand fast against wave after
wave of foes you make friends and
coordinate on some basic plans to help
safeguard the base this isn't optional
either you'll be running lots of
instances with other players you won't
know you will need their help though
most missions are challenging attacking
the things on your own generally isn't
advised tearing through zombies with
others is so easy to get right but it's
here that fortnight sets itself apart
the shooting is sharp and tight but that
feeling to clean or artificial
similarly tight communication with the
squad can help you focus on problem
monsters worming their way through your
defenses you could have someone set a
trap in a weakened area or have a friend
buttress a wall as you Clea charge out
and hurl grenades unfortunately for us
all after a few minutes that mode ends
and you enter what amounts to advanced
inventory management these missions with
others are means to several ends they're
how you gain experience and progress
your character they're how you gather
materials you'll need to make new
weapons and build out your base they're
also where you will rescue and then
retrieve survivors together all these
little elements plus plenty of even
smaller ones become the other main
thrust of fortnight monsters
at first pass these interconnected
pursuits make for tonight feel great
it's a prime example of how game working
itself around a few core ideas that
conspire to give you a lot to do but
that's just it
most of these are the end result of
missions that you play leaving combat
heavy areas is nice for a breather but
it also contrasts with all the other
systems highlighting their weaknesses
for tonight is designed to be
free-to-play but for now at least it
isn't it shouldn't be a big of a deal as
it is but it's impossible to get around
much of the game is designed to burn
time you have energy meters in the form
of research that your pack of survivors
conducts these meters place limits on
progression in that there are resource
you must wait to accumulate at the same
time they're engineered to keep you
coming back since you can only store so
many points before they need to be
collected at this point if you have
substantive experience with mobile
free-to-play games you can see what's
going on here for tonight loves giving
you extra things to do and stats to pour
over there are stats for each of your
different heroes for the defenders for
the research team is your personal
inventory and progress that's tied to
your account and then there are also
levels for each of your characters and
you can get dozens of these each of them
can be trained outfitted and upgraded
and then placed into teams that you can
align based on personality types for
maximum statistical benefit the problem
is that most of these activities aren't
interesting in and of themselves instead
of fleshing out all these individual
ideas for it it only gives you the
option to crunch for better numbers all
of these elements are linked to so if
you're not keeping up in one piece the
logistics of your operation will screech
to a halt for lack of one resource or
another for completionists that will
certainly have an appeal but others may
drop the grind currently content
dominates fortnight there's so much to
do so many skills to unlock heroes to
find quests to finish and llamas to
whack and this can cause for name to
choke on itself at times when it feels
focused however it makes a grand case
for itself there is nothing quite like
scrambling to coordinate with your team
to build out some extra turrets as you
all blast away in a last-ditch effort to
save a mission these moments for now at
least just don't come as often as they
need to the good news though is that for
tonight's issues are solvable they're a
matter of balance and tuning and
expanding upon what's there the game is
currently in early access status with a
full release plan for 2018 at that point
that will also become free-to-play so
check back then for GameSpot's updated
take on for tonight's unique mix of
looting crafting and shooting
Lama I love helping the good guys
[Music]